something like a
cambrian explosion going on with the
synthesis of intelligence the synthesis
of human decision uh
implements
initiating intelligence and then machine
intelligences that are intention
implementing
now what i want to do is to make just
three simple points today
and that is based on some buddhist
reflections that take
a relational ontology to be crucially
important to getting at the ethical
dimensions of what's going on with
intelligent technology
these three points are is that our
ethical engagement with synthetic
intelligence is being hampered by our
presupposition that the basic units of
ethical analysis
are ontologically distinct
agents actions and patients
but addressing the risks and the rewards
of intelligent technology or synthetic
intelligence
is going to depend on making a critical
distinction between tools and
technologies
and finally that the greatest risk of
intelligent technology for humanity
is not a technological singularity it's
an ethical singularity our arrival point
where the opportunity space collapses
for intelligent human course correction
so i want to come back from a buddhist
perspective and for the purpose of an
audience that doesn't have any
background familiarity with buddhism
i'll just say let's reduce buddhism to
two insights
one that everything arises
interdependently that there are no
fundamental units of reality
that everything is relational first and
foremost that relationality is more
basic than things related and finally
that everything ultimately is only what
it means for other things
the second insight is that there are two
kinds of causality and temporality
a kind of causality and temporality that
has to do with linear sequential
relations and another kind of cause
alien temporality that has to do with
immaterial non-linear significance
relations and within a buddhist context
that's referred to as karma
is the interplay the diffractive
interplay of two different kinds of
causality and temporality and according
to the teaching of karma whatever it is
that we're experiencing is the result of
consistent patterns of our own values
intentions and actions that's what
determines the kind of relational
outcomes and opportunities that we
experience in other words our worlds are
elicited by the kinds of values and
intentions that we enact
so taking together these insights
suggest a real rethinking
of the relationship that we have with
technology
between the non-duality of the
ontological and the axiological realms
that is the realms of matter and what
matters
we need to rethink consciousness in the
human world relationship because there
are relationships more like the
relationship of the two sides or edges
of a mobius strip if you look at a strip
like this it looks like there's two
edges and two sides in fact there's not
it's a three-dimensional figure that has
one side and one edge and i want to
suggest that matter and what matters
that's the physical and the phenomenal
are related in much the same way
topologically as the two sides
supposedly apparently two sides or two
edges of the mobius strip
so what this has to do with technology
is that
we normally tend to reduce because we
have the smallest bias toward there
being individual fundamental units of
reality whether they're individual
subatomic particles or forces or what
have you we tend to assume that
individuals are basic and that leads us
to misidentified tool technologies with
the tools that are used as a part of it
tools are localizable artifacts
they are
they're things ultimately
we make use of tools for specific sets
of purposes and we can evaluate tools
based on their test specific utility
with tools very importantly we have exit
rights we can decide not to use tools
how to use tools whether and when to use
tools
i'm going to suggest that technologies
are rather different technologies are
non-localizable relational systems that
transform what we do how and why
in fact we do not build
or construct or use technologies we
participate in technologies
technologies emerge out of systematic
human material and conceptual practices
in much the same way that ecosystems
emerge out of the relationships among
species
once ecosystems and species begin
co-emerging they influence one another
the recursion is taking place all the
time so that ecosystems
once they start to emerge begin to
inform the interactions of species and
the same way species are in fact
interacting with those ecosystems and
determining the evolutionary path of the
ecosystems so we're involved in
technologies in much the same way that
species are within ecosystems
to kind of see how this plays out in
terms of the importance of getting at
the ethical issues that are raised by
technology especially intelligent
technology look at the human in the loop
phenomenon
so a human in the loop is putting a
human between the observing oriented
decision making parts of this process
and the decision implementing part of
the process the last causal stage of it
and that works it's a good precaution to
address issues of machine autonomy to
make sure that the kinds of decisions
that autonomous systems are making to an
autonomous weapon system are actually in
accord with what a human would do under
the similar circumstances
what's presumed here
is that the human that's in the loop
retains evaluative independence and
freedom of intention and other words we
have an essentially external a
contingent relationship with that tool
now the conceit of independence i think
is not tenable when a human cease to be
in the loop and instead become
functionally integral loops within
intelligent technology as a dynamically
evolving relational medium
and this is happening in part because
over the last quarter century or so
there's been a displacement supplanting
of a 19th and 20th century attention
economy in which mass advertising was
used to attract and exploit human
attention to generate revenue to a
system now
we're human beings all of us that are
users of digital search digital
recommendation programs e-commerce etc
we are all now doing double duty we are
no longer external from the system we
are consumers of individually targeted
goods and services or also producers of
the training data for the systems that
are expanding processes of attention
capture and control
what that means is that while we
may presume ourselves to continue
operating within intelligent technology
as individuals
if we do that we'll see ourselves as
ontologically independent and we'll say
well what's this double duty about if we
persist in seeing ourselves as
individuals it looks as if we could
explain it as well
all that we're doing is we're
participating in a free exchange we're
giving our individual data to these
platform operators in order for them to
produce systems to give us the kinds of
things that we're asking for the
increases our choices our options are
going to be preferable and so on it's a
good deal
or it could be framed alternatively it
has look this is a predatory labor
practice that's part of surveillance
capitalism and either way whether you
take it it's the innocuous value-free
exchange or you see it as a really
predatory practice either way as long as
we assume that the individual is the
basic unit of analysis then it's just a
technical problem
all we need to do is figure out how to
ensure privacy in the first case or in
the second case how to map the kinds of
revenue streams from data generation to
data exploitation and to make sure that
individuals are given their digest
reserves
so very nice but what if we are not
what if we are not individuals what if
we are in fact implemented within this
system what if we're participating in
this medium of intelligent technology
but i think it looks rather different
because every time a machine learning
system gets greater epistemic powers to
be able to predict our behaviors our
beliefs our powers our desires our fears
they're also yielding
similarly unprecedented ontake powers to
produce behaviors and beliefs affecting
how we relate and how freely we relate
so through our participation within
these systems what we were effectively
doing is risking forfeiting our most
basic human freedoms our most basic
rights and freedoms which are the rights
to freedom of attention and freedom of
intention
i want to suggest that consciousness
matters in this we had some mention of
consciousness yesterday from a buddhist
perspective
consciousness is not a property of an
organism
it's not something that arises through
relations of an individually previously
existing organism and its environment an
external objective environment
rather consciousness consists in the
coherent differentiation
of organisms and their environments or
sensing presences and sensed presences
so the body
brain environment relations are
elaborations of an infrastructure of
consciousness they're materializations
of what consciousness does
consciousness is not a thing it doesn't
exist in a thing like matter
consciousness is a relational dynamic
that performs things in the world and
what it performs is coherent
differentiation
so consciousness
is evolution where evolution is
consciousness mattering
that we cannot separate out
consciousness from what's going on
material around the world so this is a
buddhist perspective
there is however some evidence to
support this neuroscientifically
we have evidence that if you're looking
at what's happening in psychedelic
experiences and meditative experiences
what's most valued in those experiences
at documented and first-person reporting
on the experiences correlates with
third-person measurements
neuroscientifically through brain
imaging
of increased brain entropy what that
suggests is that these very valued
experiences for meditation and from
psychedelic use are not
uh important valuable for neural reasons
their importance is not
intracranial they're important
extracranial and it connects with
theorizing of consciousness that sees
what's going on in consciousness as
dissolving the default mode network that
is a part of the neurological system
that supports sort of ego or
self-supporting narratives but when
buddhism would be theorized as the work
of the seventh consciousness sort of
subjective consciousness we can get into
buddhism and eight consciousnesses later
but basically what we're doing in these
psychedelic and meditative experiences
is dissolving habits of thought feeling
and action that normally constrain our
ability to pay attention and that limit
our responsiveness so in a sense what's
going on in these experiences
is that we're minimizing consciousness
it's minimizing relational entropy by
enhancing ecological differentiation
and our responsiveness our ability to
create different forms of coherence
so third point is that inter-brain
entanglement is affected by what we
think or expect to be true there are
these very very
insightful experiments that have been
done where humans can engage in
collaborative tasks
and when you engage in collaborative
tests neural systems brainwave systems
those patterns coordinate
that's only happening when you are
collaborating not when you're competing
interesting first point
second point when people are given the
task to collaborate with one another
they're doing it online through a
computer interface and they're told
sometimes you're working with a human
sometimes you're working with an ai
in the cases where they believe they're
working with another human
both humans their brain waves coordinate
if they think that they're working with
an ai instead
their brain waves don't coordinate even
though they're always working with a
human being and what this suggests is
that inter-brain entanglement is going
on through collaborative dynamics that
our consciousness-based it's our
intentionality what we believe in what
we think that is affecting the neural
structure so consciousness has causal
agency it has causal reality so unlike
the physicalist reductionists who would
say that
consciousness doesn't have any more
cause of relevance than the report of a
gun being shot does on the trajectory of
a bullet that consciousness actually is
causally relevant what we believe what
we think is causally relevant how are
our beliefs shaped well partly by
consciousness itself be engaged one
another through shared interaction and
communication so on but
in the same way the transportation
infrastructure can limit what you can do
in terms of transportation we follow the
streets the roads has
once conscious infrastructure has been
developed we tend to follow that
intelligent technology is implicating us
in developing a new kind of
infrastructure for consciousness which
will both in some ways liberate and in
some ways constrain human agency
so what's going on i think with
intelligent technology wittingly or
unwittingly
is mass experimentation and hacking in
the infrastructure of consciousness
using machine learning tools to predict
and produce behaviors is ethically
analogous to inserting brain electrodes
into the brain to manipulate human
behavior you know that you can put
electrodes in the brain and get people
to have an arm go up and people will say
when asked why did your arm go up they
will answer uh i wanted to scratch my
hair scratch my head
because there's nothing in the
evolutionary development of this
infrastructure of human consciousness
that could explain
how your hand moved up by itself so what
the system wants to say is i must have
been responsible for that
reductionists have looked at that as
proof
brain first consciousness second
consciousness causally irrelevant but
these studies that i've just cited show
that that's not the case consciousness
is in fact causing irrelevant so that
when we're hacking the infrastructure
consciousness whether it's the brain
infrastructure neural infrastructure the
body environment relationship
infrastructure or the cultural patterns
that we're participating in where
culture is also an external
infrastructure for consciousness and
especially for shared consciousness now
what's going on with these machine
learning tools is it's the equivalent of
inserting
algorithmic electrodes into the
connective tissue of shared human
consciousness
so
someone might object that well look
we could just change the objective
function of the machine learning systems
instead of
extracting
holding and exploiting human attention
why don't we design machine learning
systems that will figure out what is
entailed in compassionate behavior for
example compassionate relations and we
can have that be the objective function
and realize systems that will allow us
to all enjoy compassionate relations
with one another to increase that to get
that part of what's hardwired into the
infrastructure of human consciousness
might sound like a good idea but i think
we have to be really worried about
ironic consequences because it brings to
mind the specter of past projects
and eugenics
and with the very very difficult
question of asking well if we were to do
that if we're going to engineer
ourselves to be human
if we're going to enter ourselves to be
ethical by design
then whose ethics
from which time period according to
which culture which historical era
is the present time period and this is a
real question about ethics is ethics
fixed
or should ethics be an improvisational
art in which we're all engaged the
improvisation of the values of art a
changing human choruses in ways that
responsive to our environments and in
ways that are conducive
in buddhist terms to living in
relational dynamics that are less
conflicted less troubled and full of
less suffering
thank you there's a nice image to end
that's great thanks so much peter um and
next up we have smitha from uc berkeley